because when you have a record like i
spy which is like like you said it's
diamond it's not diamond but it's gonna
be diamonds it's like
seven
crazy going eight times insane and it
streams like two hundred and fifty
million times a year
it's like one of those insane hit record
anomalies and was it like a curse and i
mean obviously you're going to love the
money you'll love the i mean
that should put a lot of money in your
pocket but like um is there a curse
that's the reason i can go independent i
never need to be with
i probably never need to be with a major
again
because of that song you know it's
amazing and it's like that's
where my true joy is coming from me
being able to do art the way i want to
do it not because i have to do it in
order to make money financial pillow
exactly yeah but do you think like just
in terms of like atlantic's perspective
when that's like your first i mean i
guess kind of your first record with
them yeah
and it's like a diamond song yeah it
kind of like
the expectation now is like exactly so
it's like no matter what and you're like
yo i'm like an artist i do like cool
artistic [ __ ] yeah i'm like i got here
for a reason but now i'm
those guys are gonna have you be like
yeah well we gotta follow this up
straight up and that's why i that's why
i don't like take anything away from
them and what they're trying to do i
think just for me
like the situation just no longer fits
what makes what brings me joy and that's
what life is about you feel me having as
much joy as possible until
you finally are no longer here and i
think
yeah it just didn't add up for bringing
me joy anymore because it's like y'all
one
you're like our idea for how to pop this
off is just to me to shoot tic tocs like
i can do that on my own right straight
up yeah thanks to the advice thank you
for the advice then two it's like
okay
yeah that that song that y'all want me
to follow up is like a once in a
generational song
like so i can't dedicate the next five
years of my career to just trying to put
that on the board i'm not gonna have fun
i need to be able to go just do [ __ ] i
want to do without feeling like i'm
letting you all down every time like i
said like now we going left [ __ ] kyle
please right
nah i can't